attendu de pied ferme ok Canada a plutôt
opté pour une sellette virtuelle alors
que les appels à la démission se
multiplient une admission du bout des
lèvres
et beaucoup de travail qui auraient pu
être fait plus tôt malgré tout ok Canada
se défend bec et
l'utilisation de fonds secrets pour
régler les plaintes d'agression sexuelle
était selon elle approprié et les appels
à la démission exagérées
de salissage dans les médias et à
l'inverse dit-elle le directeur de
l'organisme mérite un a pour son bon
travail
l'évaluation des députés est plus sévère
ils exigeaient des réponses ils sont
restées sur leurs fins
pouvez-vous dire combien d'argent il
reste dans le fond pour les agressions
sexuelles à tes points
ma question elle est très simple qui est
imputable
on pose des questions ils ont pas de
réponse c'est comme c'est négligence de
préparation pour le comité parlementaire
à chaque semaine pour qu'ils comprennent
qu'il faut que le dirigeant démissionne
depuis le début de l'été c'est scandale
après scandale il y en a un chaque
semaine là ça suffit il faut faire toute
la lumière une fois pour toute les
parties de position veulent une enquête
indépendante de son côté le gouvernement
augmente à nouveau la pression ce qu'on
entendu aujourd'hui évidemment c'est pas
ce que j'espérais des audiences un appel
à ok Québec et à toutes les autres
fédérations de hockey au pays à sortir
de leur mutisme je me retourne vers les
membres votants qui peuvent changer les
choses qui Canada au niveau du conseil
d'administration après avoir suspendu
son financement les leviers du
gouvernement face à ok Canada sont
limités
Ottawa transporte donc son bras de fer
sur la scène de l'opinion publique
pendant que ok Canada tente de protéger
son image de marque ici Christian Noël
Radio-Canada Ottawa